welcome to the DS show I'm a two-year
host and it's Ramadan it's that time of
the year and I bet you if you sit tight
there are in this episode several
questions has probably been on your mind
that we're going to answer on this
week's show specially for Ramadan and
those fasting in Ramadan and those who
want to know about Ramadan we'll be
right back this is the this is the venue
this is the days of the theme this is
the theme Jew I said I like Oh greetings
of peace hello how are you sure I'm
doing excellent elite Ramadan special
episode we want to go ahead and first
start off with what is Ramadan what's
the whole purpose of Ramadan right so
I'm the Ramadan is the month in which
the Quran was revealed to the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him so it's
special
so Allah chose that month to be special
where we get extra rewards for doing
things and we're going to be fasting in
this month of Ramadan why fast why what
was the whole prayer I got starved
myself now everybody's eating
I got to go hungry yeah it's a very good
question so the thing is when you're
fasting you're keeping away from three
things you're avoiding food you're
avoiding drink you're avoiding
intercourse during the day from dawn
until sunset now if you think about the
three things that God asked us to stay
away from these are like the three human
like the strongest human desires that we
have everyone's got to eat everyone you
know everyone gets hungry everyone needs
to eat something everyone needs to drink
something and there's a very strong urge
for you know intercourse that you know
human beings have that intimacy and
wanting to be with someone and all of
that so when you can train yourself to
resist these three desires for a period
of time you can resist all the other
things which are prohibited for you you
know you can you're lying you know
you're going and drinking alcohol you're
doing drugs you can stay away from all
those things because you
someone gives you some weed someone
gives you some beer some of that and
you're like man I I stayed away from
water you know in the summer months you
know so it's like a training program
basically you train yourself so that you
can get self discipline and that self
discipline will lead you to get closer
to allah and become a better servant of
god beautiful I am going to we have some
questions compiled that I bet most
people out there they've wanted to ask
these maybe they still on their minds
we're going to try to go through many of
these questions and hopefully you can
answer them God willing insha'Allah
children when should children start
fasting yeah that's a common question uh
children the same time when they start
praying so the Prophet peace be upon him
he said that when children reached the
age of seven they should start praying
and when they reached the age of ten you
should parents should discipline that
meaning like in force that they're
actually going to be praying and the
same thing applies for fasting so they
should start fasting when they're seven
years old try to you know learn what
fasting is fast three days a month seven
days whatever they can handle
they got age seven age eight age nine
where they're just testing it out they
try whenever they can if they get hungry
they can break it it's okay once they
hit the age of ten they need to be
fasting every single day in the month of
Ramadan how sick does someone have to be
to skip fasting yeah so that's the thing
so if someone is sick they don't have to
fast so if you have a major illness you
have the flu you have some type of
chronic illness or whatever you don't
need to fast so if you're if your body
is being harmed by fasting harm to like
an actual extent right like a serious
extent if your the flu you need liquids
you know to be able to get through this
this time you don't need to fast but if
you got like a little cough you know you
know little nose running or something
like that or you know at school they're
like oh you're gonna have to run half a
mile today I can't do that you know it's
too difficult most people can get
through it you know so you're not
allowed to break your fast or skip
fasting if it's something very small
like it's not going to harm your body
the moment is going to be harming your
body and it's going to cause like major
repercussions you know for the following
days
or longer period of time that's when you
want that that's that's when the where
the where the limit basically is how
about pregnant women should a fast
that's a good question you know pregnant
women they should ask their and consult
with their physician they should ask
their doctor to see if it's safe for
them to fast because I've actually heard
of cases where women were fasting
depends on how long the day is if they
became dehydrated or whatever it can
potentially affect their baby and affect
them as well so they should really
consult with their doctor if they give
them the okay then they can fast if they
don't give them the okay they should not
go out of their way that would
potentially harm their body or their
baby and go ahead and fast anyways what
about breastfeeding women that's a
common question as well yeah so with
their breastfeeding and that's going to
somehow fasting is going to stop the
milk supply or something like that
they're allowed to skip that as well so
that is okay if breastfeeding women they
are not able to pump and keep the milk
and feed the baby later or something
like that they can also skip fasting
what about women who continuously get
pregnant at the same time now Ramadan
comes around and they keep breastfeeding
how do they feel into it fit into this
yeah so what can happen is you know if
you if you're pregnant and then you're
breastfeeding for a year or two years
and then you're pregnant again in that
period of time several Ramadan's can go
by and you haven't fasted in several
years and you didn't get a chance to
make it up either because you were
continuously in that state so in that
case you're considered to be a person
who's like in a chronic you know
inability to be able to fast so you
don't need to go ahead and make those up
instead you can do what people who have
a chronic illness can do and that is
feed one poor person every day that you
missed a fasting for you too poor purse
feed a poor person
what if someone has a chronic illness
now right so anyone who has any type of
chronic illness diabetes or they're just
someone who's very elderly in age it's
very very difficult for them to be able
to get through because of their health
issues their health conditions that they
have they don't need to fast because you
know Allah has made it easy for people
he doesn't want to overburden people and
make sure that they're doesn't want
their help to get messed up or something
like that so what they do instead for
every single day of fasting that they
miss they just feed one poor person for
one poor person for every single fast
that they're missing so if it's 30 days
of normal
on you miss all 30 days you're going to
be feeding 30 poor people I travel a lot
for a person traveling how do they
incorporate the fasting yeah so when
you're traveling you have an exception
to the rule you have the option to not
fast so because fast you traveling is
usually a difficult thing it takes a
toll on people they're in an airplane or
something like that so you can skip
fasting while you're in a state of
travel but the thing to keep in mind is
that you don't have to skip fasting some
people have a misconception that if
you're traveling I'm going from you know
I'm flying from here one hour distance
away an airplane I'm traveling
technically to have to break my fast if
it's easy for you to fast it's better to
fast but if you feel that there's
actually going to be some level of
difficulty and hardship involved then
you have the option to not fast and make
it up later
we got one more before we go to break
Ramadhan starting and ending at
different times in different messages
what should a person do yeah this is an
issue because there are some different
opinions in terms of how ramada or when
Ramadan should be starting and when it
should be ending and it has to do with
global sighting of the moon versus a
local sighting of the moon versus after
using astronomical calculations my
advice is go with the Masjid which you
feel is like your home motion you feel
comfortable there you feel comfortable
with the Islamic scholarship there and
what's really really important is if
that must is not following the opinion
that you hold go ahead and set the
opinion that you hold aside and go with
that much it anyways and make sure that
your family is not divided keep the
family together some families they split
and they go oh I'm going with that
message and I'm going to start Ramadan
on one day I'm sorry Ramallah on another
day the family should be kept together
and that's very very important because
there are different opinions on this
issue and there are legitimate
differences of opinion so we shouldn't
cause this to become a division for even
especially a locality that's ten down of
the questions that most commonly are as
during Ramadan we'll be back with more
god woman don't go anywhere
fasting makes you feel hunger which
every poor person suffers from in the
world this is how you would sympathize
with the poor and try to help them
this is why every Muslim is required to
give food to the poor immediately by the
end of Ramadan the basic rules of
fasting are avoiding food drink and
sexual intercourse between dawn and
sunset in the month of Ramadan other
levels must be added to have real impact
on the fasting person the basic level of
fasting will not benefit one spiritually
except from the perspective of
submission to divine instructions
thus the ritual level alone will not
purify one of sin the deeper meaning of
fasting is training the spirit to
control desires restraining the spirit
from the lawful human desires for a
while during fasting makes the person
more capable of preventing himself from
committing anything unlawful at all
times not only fasting time it helps him
control the negative human emotions like
anger it also helps the person to
overcome greed stinginess and hatred
this is what the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him said Allah has no need for
the hunger and the thirst of the person
who does not restrain himself from
telling lies and acting on them even
while observing the fast welcome back to
the Deen show questions during Ramadan
fifth pillar of Islam one is to agree
that there's nothing worthy of worship
except the creator of the heavens and
earth Jesus Moses Abraham Muhammad is
the last and final messenger including
not excluding all those that preceded
him and giving the poor do these ikot
the Ramadan which we are now right and
Hajj pilgrimage pilgrimage but the one
we're focusing on right now and salat
praying five times minimum a day Aslam
is very simple and easy to understand
we cover why we fast real briefly but
now these are questions that are on the
mind of many people now the next
question that I have is the different
timetables that people have at mustards
and this can create some confusion well
you have two out yeah so the thing is
when we're determining the fudger time
and we're determining the aja time
there's a different there's different
ways to calculate that whether you use
18 degrees or 15 degrees in terms of how
low the Sun is below
horizon so these are these are
calculations which are very they're not
absolute so what has happened actually
is people try to estimate this a if we
want to find out exactly what the prayer
time is in a particular region what is a
good estimate to use that will apply
across the board
unfortunately it changes wherever you
are depending on where you are on the
earth which country you're in which
state you're in even so the thing is
most people they're not able to go
outside and see the horizon to determine
for themselves so there's gonna be a
little bit difference in timing when it
comes to the calendar that you're
getting so what you really should do is
I would recommend for the average person
who can't investigate in detail go with
their local scholars council that's
actually determining what this calendar
is and whatever you know degrees that
they fixed after doing proper research
don't worry about there being some
discrepancy in timing vomiting those
vomiting someone will ask does that
break my fast yeah so thought of a
common question yeah it's a common
question if you vomit intentionally it
will break your fast but if you vomit
unintentionally just you just overcome
by it then that's not going to break
your fast so you don't induce fom if you
induce vomiting for yourself someone has
an issue or whatever it is that will
break your fast so I don't think I can
think of it as crazy but you know you
used to be a model you came to Islam you
know hey I was thinking the same thing
your sleeve so you want to keep your
petite so that you can't be doing that
right you can't be doing that okay next
one is it okay to take these drops
eyedrops
different yeah medication eyedrops ear
drops nose drops all these things as
long as you're not swallowing them
they're not you know the air canal no
eyes they're not going to be going into
your mouth your nose drops you just want
to make sure if it gets down into your
throat you don't swallow even if you
have to take enema as a medicine or
something like that all of these things
are fine they don't break your fast
because they don't really nourish you
and they don't make it down into your
stomach medical injections medical
injections also suffers so it depends on
what you're injecting so if you're
injecting something that is not
nourishing it doesn't resemble food like
if you're getting let's say a vaccine
you know you're getting a
you're getting insulin or something like
that this is not considered to be
nourishing so it does not break your
fast just the needle going in does not
break your fast it depends what's in
there but if you are hospitalized and
they're putting glucose in your body
glucose nourishes you that's what it
does right so it's like you're basically
drinking so in that sense it will break
your fast so it depends what's going in
if it's nourishing if it's going to the
stomach it's going to break your fast if
it's not nourishing it just goes into
your bloodstream and it's not really
changing anything late it doesn't
resemble food in any way shape or form
then in that case it's not going to
break your fast beautiful continuing on
answering your question I told you
you're going to sit tight and there's
probably many of these that are on your
mind you didn't get a chance to ask we
got someone who can go ahead and give us
the answers mouthwash yeah so mouthwash
is something that I would recommend
people avoid I would say that it's
disliked because the thing is it's it's
usually not necessary you usually can
brush your teeth brushing your teeth
would be okay but when it comes to using
mouthwash you're kind of gargling many
people will gargle try and get in the
back there I would stay avoid it but it
wouldn't break your fast if you're using
it okay I've had the you know the
morning before dawn meal right hood
before and now the day goes by and maybe
I'm flossing and oh I got that little
piece it went down a little bit of food
that I swallowed yes what happens here
yes so again this is a unintentional so
what happens is you have the pre-dawn
meal some you're eating some poppy seed
whatever it may be kind of stuck in your
teeth and all of a sudden you're like
kind of picking at it and all of a
sudden just comes in your mouth you
swallow it it's perfectly fine because
you did it accidentally if you eat or
drink accidentally even if you eat I
mean totally forgetful II you eat a
quarter of a burger or something like
that and then you remember all of a
sudden you got to stop immediately
if you've got food in your mouth you
spit the rest out and you resume your
fasting it did not break your fast good
these are multiplied during the month of
ramadhan absolutely so I want to give
blood yes is that acceptable absolutely
so what happened with blood it it can
potentially weaken you so if you're
giving blood if it
we can you to the point where it's
making your fasting very difficult for
you it's better not to give blood but if
you're okay when you give blood you
don't really get weak you're perfectly
fine you can walk around everything's
going to be fine there's nothing wrong
with giving blood it's not going to
break your fast asthma inhalers asthma
inhalers as well so there's a difference
of opinion among scholars on this but I
believe it's okay because it's going
into the lungs and it's not really
nourishing your body in any way so
that's considered to not break your fast
someone might ask is it okay to wear
perfume or any of colognes during
Ramadan I recognize that
yeah I've been asked that so some people
think that because you're going to be
inhaling it you're smelling it's like
incense and it's like smoke you know
going into your mouth or something so
just simply smelling perfume is not
going to break your fast there's nothing
wrong with it at all okay so it's
encouraging smell good all the time
absolutely okay but what about the
distinction now with the man and the
woman the way yes of course there's
there's an issue of women wearing very
strong perfume that's going to be luring
and enticing men so they should be
careful about that right so that that's
something that is not allowed in Islam
I'm moving along we're flying through
many of these important questions
someone it gets hot right very hot
sometimes you're working outside or just
being outside and now you want to cool
off you know taking some knows and some
some water and gargling right lashing it
on you and your nose yeah so that's
perfectly fine I mean you can you can go
and you know rinse your mouth with water
kind of just moistens it you know and
some people will say well but some water
goes in your water is absorbed by your
tongue it goes into your body yes it
does but you're not intentionally going
in and swallowing it so it's allowed you
do that in will do when you're
performing will do you're making a blue
ssin you're going to be putting water in
your mouth while you're fasting as well
so the Prophet peace be upon him did it
it's allowed you want to take a bath you
want to take a shower or some of that
cool down it's getting a little bit
tough last few hours of fasting in
summertime you can go ahead go ahead
jump in a tub or something like that
it's perfectly fine to cool down
beautiful we just got through 21
questions we got another nine left I
want to get through and I'm sure you do
also so don't go anywhere we'll be right
back here on the D show don't wait
around the essence of the sciences of
self-development and management of time
resources in the world call for one
important principle control your desires
and do not let them control you in this
age of gratification many things are
used to fulfill human desires as soon as
they have them the ability to delay
gratification is an important skill and
fasting helps in developing such skill
fasting is primarily between the person
and Allah and because of this intimate
aspect of fasting Allah was quoted by
the Prophet as saying every act of
Adam's descendants is for themselves
except fasting it is meant for me alone
and I alone will give the reward for it
just wanna wanna live easy Nephi who
delivers your vanity meanin Buddha
wonderful born family dummy who shall
Raphael
back here on the Dean show we're talking
about Ramadan people are fasting as
their connection to their Creator as it
was prescribed to those before you is
prescribed upon you that you may
increase in taqwa
what is it tuck up someone saying what
is that Rilke what was that mean tough
walk tough what means you become you're
conscious of God you think about God all
the time and whenever you're doing
something you remember that God is
watching you
that's what it means to have taqwa
someone says okay I miss the fast how
quickly should I make up the fast yeah
so ideally you should try to make it up
as soon as you can some people want to
take a little bit break or whatever it
is you have to make it up by the next
ramalon that's like if you if you delay
for an entire year until the next
Ramadan comes and you haven't made up
the fast that you were supposed to make
up then you can be sinful for that but
prior to that you should try to make it
up you know in a reasonably sufficient
time after a few weeks if you need to
maybe a month or so
you shouldn't delay too long but you
should never ever exceed until the next
Ramadan comes and you're like I don't
have time to make it up now if someone
broke their fast they did with just two
hungry right yeah they just ended up
breaking their fast that cheeseburgers
whatever that looked looked too good
they and they ate their friend had it
and they just kept you know
I'm pushing them you know teasing them
maybe shouldn't be around watching that
so they ended up breaking it fast do
they just pray to God Almighty Allah to
forgive them and just move on what do
they do in this case continue the fast
or or no it's gone for that day right so
I mean they should the first they should
refrain from fasting the rest of the day
even though they're fast is technically
broken now when you break your fast in
Ramadan intentionally like this you're
like you know I just I just want to eat
man I just I'm just hungry I don't want
to fast anymore is there's no medical
condition there's no legitimate excuse
this is a very serious thing and there's
a penalty for it as well and the penalty
for doing that is well we can't free a
slave anymore so the other penalty is
that you have to actually make up 60
days of continuous consecutive fasts
because you broke your faster than Allah
it's not a joke at all this is a penalty
that's been prescribed by the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
so many people don't know that they're
like oh well it's just one I'll just
make it up no you're not just making up
one now you're being penalized you have
to make up 60 consecutively in a row
without breaking it and that's the
penalty for breaking for basically what
you're doing you're violating the
sanctity of the month of Ramadan and
that's a very serious thing
if you acts so we talked about if you
accidentally let's say you unconsciously
you drink some water
you know man it's exactly so that's
that's different so you unconsciously
did it you forgetful II did it that's
understandable your fast is not broken
it's overlooked but you are deliberately
saying you know what I'm I just don't
want to fast anymore man that that's
that's when you get penalized for it
that's you like rebelling against a
longe is saying you know what I just I
can't take the same I just want to eat a
burger man I'm hungry yeah you just gone
against a you know a major major command
of Allah you got against one of the
pillars of Islam and most of us don't
know what starving is starving actually
occurs man after several days of not
eating so that's technically absolutely
absolutely so that's that's not
excusable tell us some people ask ok I
go to the taraweeh prayer some places
ate some places is 20 yeah so you know
what there are different opinions on
this there's different ways the Prophet
peace be
punim did not specify the number in 100%
clear detail in terms of thorough BIA
so if some luncheon is praying ate your
another one's praying 20 some people
make it a big deal I don't go to that 20
month or the other I don't go to that
much of where they pray eight it's okay
both of these are acceptable opinions
and there are other opinions as well in
my malik another scholar said you could
pray 36 you could pray another number so
it's not the number that you're praying
it's that are we that you're actually
praying the fact that you're breaking
them up in twos and you're taking breaks
in between that's what are we is all
about so don't make it into a huge deal
or something to debate about it's okay
if you pray either one so so the control
filter when people ask when one does
need to be paid arises so this sort of
qatal fitter sometimes it's called zakat
or filter but it's not the normal zakah
this fitrah that you pay is basically
something you give before the day of eat
before ramadan ends so that you're
giving it to those people who are in
need and they don't have to work on the
day rate some people they live literally
is this a hand-to-mouth you know they
need to make their living for that day
everyone deserves to enjoy and celebrate
the day right right so what you're doing
is when every Muslim gives a certain
amount of money to those people who
really are deserving who really need it
so that they don't need to work on the
day of Eid they can enjoy the day
themselves as well so you should be
giving this every much it usually
solicits it and they ask okay well you
know what it's time to pay now we have a
box going around they set what the
amount is the amount is a certain amount
of foodstuffs depending on what is
calculated sometimes it's like eight
dollars sometimes it's like fifteen
dollars it's really not that much but so
you need to give that you need to give
it on behalf of your family members as
well and it's very important you don't
wait to the last minute and the reason
why I want to emphasize that is when you
wait till the last minute most
organizations Islamic organizations they
don't have the means to distribute it to
the right people in time so I would say
try to give it at least one week before
I'm about ends or two weeks before I'm
about ends and don't wait till the last
minute don't wait to the last minute a
few more questions dentist can I go to
the dentist
yeah so the thing is when you're going
to the dentist usually they got a lot of
water going into your mouth and you know
it's it's so you kind of uh you know
unintentionally
going to be getting a lot of water being
swallowed unintentionally so you should
try to schedule your dentistry work and
your appointments and all of that around
the month of ramadhan as much as much as
possible swimming some people want to
know can I go swimming during Remini
yeah so if you generally are not going
to be swallowing water you know how to
swim and you know it's not going to be
going into your mouth then you're
allowed to go ahead go go swimming
especially if you need to do it as a
career or something like that it's
permissible but just make sure you're
not swallowing any water yeah and make
sure you're swimming in a nice light
environment and make sure you're
something I could clean and modest
environment
do I have to renew my intention every
night for fast yeah that's another
common question the thing is you
actually don't so you can make an
intention to fast a whole month of
ramadhan and as long as you're fasting
every single day you wake up in the
morning you already know that you're
going to be fast even if it wasn't
conscious you made the intention for the
whole month but if you get sick in the
middle of the month and then you don't
fast you need to renew your intention in
terms of now I'm going to be restarting
my fasting again so you can make the
intention for the entire block of time
and that will suffice as well someone's
asking can I pray with her behind an
imam who prays it a different way yeah
so there are some people who make the
the supplication the dua outloud there
are some people who do three-straight
some people who pray two units and then
they do one unit and some people feel
like I can't pray behind that imam he
doesn't pray the way that I pray my
whitter the way that I was taught I mean
there are differences of opinion on this
it's okay to pray behind an imam as long
as he's following a legitimate opinion
within Islamic scholarship so the way
that it works is when you're praying
behind an imam you will be following the
opinions of the imam that you're
following and they become your own
opinion so it's okay so if even if you
know the imam is praying a little bit
different than you you can follow what
you're doing but it's not going to break
your prayer it's not going to be any
problem so this is perfectly fine now
you're staying staying in taraweeh
prayer and you're listening to the imam
and some people hold the most off or
maybe an iPad with an app quran app
loud so the thing is it shouldn't be
done the reason why it shouldn't be done
is one it's very distracting for people
next to you obviously people are trying
to concentrate you have a light emitting
device you know your cell phone up there
or something like that you're making a
lot of movements to if you're holding
almost half a copy of the Quran when you
go down into your prostration you got to
hold it up somehow and you're not able
to do the correct things I mean the
thing is we don't do this during our
five daily prayers right we pray and we
we read whatever surahs we're reading
and we read whatever Quran we know and
if we're praying behind an imam whatever
the imam decides to read we just we stay
there and we kind of listen along i know
people try to do it because they like to
follow along and i understand that
mentality but that's not the ultimate
purpose of prayer you could do that read
your on outside of prayer so it's not
something that should be a standard
practice so some scholars may have
permitted it but there's a lot of
excessive movement in motion I would
recommend is better not to these type of
things we did it thirty questions under
eleven the most common questions as
during Ramadan absolutely that's it any
advice for people now this Ramadan
before we come to a to an end
that's it I just I I you know Ramadan
people have a lot of questions and
sometimes they're too shy to ask the
questions and you should you should not
shy away it's better to have knowledge
than to remain in ignorance so ask the
people of knowledge
some people just grab their phone number
your local Imam if he's willing to share
your number his number with you you can
text message him questions text people
back I do it every single Ramadan go and
take a class on Ramadan go read up a
little bit try to understand so you can
prepare yourself really well and you
have a good you will have the best
Ramadan aim to have the best Ramadan
you've ever had you want to make sure
you end that Ramadan being closer to
Allah than you were the previous Ramadan
Abraham said peace Moses said peace
jesus said peace muhammad the last and
final messenger he also greeted with
this greeting we started with an ending
with peace be with you I said I want to
be with you Atticus Salaam and just as
they greeted with peace and they
submitted to the owner of peace because
you cannot get peace in a six-pack a
Budweiser or smoking that dope or that
ganja all day and night and just
partying and kicking it now
was the time to reflect really you've
tuned in to the Dean show you've been
led here for a reason if you're not yet
Muslim this is the way of life that
we're living that Jesus lived Moses live
Abraham look all the preceding
messengers that came before Mohammed
Mohammed is just the last they all came
with the same message worship the
Creator not the creation and do good
deeds prepare for the Day of Judgment
because life is short it's going to end
at any time and they fasted and that's
what we're doing this month the Ramadan
I hope you had a chance to enjoy and
benefit from these questions subscribe
if you haven't already and we'll see you
next time until then peace be with you
it's not like thank God I'm doing a lot
we've been doing this over 10 years 500
plus episodes and we bring on some of
the most amazing guests so we're going
to have a lot of fun cover a lot of
ground a lot of exciting topics you
don't want to miss out you want to be
here every Friday and then we'll try to
give you some short reminders in between
but you can't get that if you're not
coming back to the show every week
Friday's will be releasing it God
willing inshallah subscribe right now
and enjoy all of the content that we're
going to be putting out for you thank
you peace be with you so I'm like and
don't forget as I asked you to do
already if you have it subscribed right
now